welcome to this video playing Rick's on
Gracie JJ who prove who the heck is that
this somewhat into account on her okay
so let's see going to play the classical
and that a six now sir the normal way to
continue and now I can go push up cheat
or can do lettuces rather save but let's
let's go for that
okay takes a little bit of a timeout
after Bishop t to the pretty long thing
actually for such a normal position yeah
black will probably play rook c8 and and
be okay it's a pretty typical limassol
position where blacks flexibility is
helping him a lot now you have not
played the deep on yet so you can keep
it back on D seven so that it's so
difficult to attack or you can play t5
if the moment is right he's really
spending a long time him
yeah like an i go through CHS very
normal yeah sure this is can be played
as well okay let's take it and here ball
to a 40 be three of them it gets go to a
for Bishop a three digit before I we
probably have some trades now yeah okay
it's very safe very safe way to play but
I am perfectly honest if I'm playing
someone with the rating of 2400 from in
completely from a non chess playing
country like Brazil where there maybe
like 15 to 20 people who could reach
that kind of rating on the ICC five min
the pool I tend to be very cautious
because of cheating so I'm just playing
super solid and see what happens i mean
his some whole way of spending time and
so on doesn't indicate cheating at all
I'm just saying I'm starting out with a
pretty solid mindset if I'm playing
someone untitled with such high rating
and so on um yeah it's very very boring
position just having all of that
diagonal I mean a much better on the
clock and you keep spending lots of time
yeah maybe like oopsy for some kind of
idea it looks kind of wrong yeah let's
do that maybe that makes them spend even
more time tending Quincy to keeping the
C file p 5 @ XE Edwards check so that's
no good okay um yeah maybe to c5 on yeah
let's go to c5 was thinking maybe
Queenie for so ever the drilling is just
is just equal doesn't really make a huge
difference what you play if I go a for
the screen a 6 yes so I'm going to take
it
and now nitey xmen okay 94 or 95 mm what
what am I going to do here maybe 94 95
96 might be a little bit of activity me
nothing really to write home about but
maybe 95 a 696 queen bee to Quincy a
check and taking on that cell no it
cannot be worse for me really I think so
why not
hey catching up somewhat here on the
clock maybe takes me to it might get
somewhat interesting I mean him I
probably has couldn't be 124 for a draw
now he probably has that him he can take
on me too and if I check there yep and I
have two check check he's got that
queendom could be one Queen e-form I
take up seven Queen B 1 kingi to Queenie
for check and this is a draw I can take
a six is this some kind of tribe or is
that a stupid idea okay I'm taking this
to avoid that immediate draw with Queen
be one night only success covering them
discovering a form
vice really taking ages check okay so
it's got that check on f4 going for him
if I go queen bee seven check king of
three I can just go f6 anywhere that's
really really not much going on coming
back it is just very Jewish I have to
speed up at least come on I mean I know
it's a draw basicly word still can i
post some can I can go Quincy 898 maybe
you cannot play up seats now easily I
light h3 maybe night h3 can play
I'm not offering a drawing this is just
too hard to to I mean he's just spending
ages and then let the clock run down
okay if I take a for a my chick made it
if I am then it's really funny how time
morning I don't see how actually am i
checkmated ye five chick I don't see it
black I hope I'm not checkmate that
would be no I'm not her name yeah I
don't know yeah i was super slow very
weird way of playing I think I mean he
played perfectly no I mean just never
speeding up in the simplified position
was kind of weird okay yeah Bishop t2
edited already I mean why why take like
30 seconds on that and so on yeah anyway
so it was a very very boring game
actually as I said if the handle seems
kind of hmm to me I attend to tend to be
extra cautious and oh yeah not much
what's going on I tried a little bit
here with that did that thing with he
took it yeah yeah yeah I know night of
70 he can at least draw with Queen
behind this year chinese draw this is
why I avoided it but the computer
actually says that I can play oops not
like this that black can play for win
here actually yeah I thought that well
you have to make with decision that this
would be kind of dangerous for blacks
king but yeah I don't even have this
queria so black is better here
okay so this was the right decision
maker making it and making it equal this
move ya know if I do something like
Queen B seven um they can just play up
six and nothing happens I went back King
g8 check ok trying trying something now
at least he cannot move the f porn I
came a beginner player 59 f seven there
are some things that so this is why I
continued Chad this is right yeah no no
not age three I saw that move and this
is like I think a draw because I cannot
take because of Jess I think it seems he
didn't see that and otherwise he loses a
pawn or what what you did giving up
giving up denied now quit takes you to
actually it's possible and just given s
equal by the computer well g5 is mate
its mate threat Wow
that's amazing 94 f5 Quincy 6s the
engine line but that King opponent game
is so that winning or not hmm could be
winning four wide now I think it's wrong
no that's it oh I think check check it's
probably a draw kingi 1615 of seven and
now that's a drop okay now there's no
way forward what can gain lots of space
there but ultimately not leading to much
it's a draw okay well thanks for
watching